bon on a on a pour jouer avec mon âge il
commet savamment gil ben ça va être quoi
pékin cyril je suis content de te voir
l'appareil l'idem et mangent ils
habitent ou à l'avenir hier dans le 78
je connais très bien géré j'ai traîné
mes guêtres là bas où ça exactement à
deux pas de chez toi au top
tu fais quoi dans la vie je suis en
recherche d'emploi la bon d'accord mon
chéri était confiné avec qui avec ma
compagne bon ça va aller elle est en
forme tout va bien tout va bien vous
êtes contents tous les jours vous aimez
toujours bon super jeu content que mon
chéri on va faire un jeu et vous allez
jouer avec toucher vous également qu'il
sera plus fort que les chroniqueurs
gilles a joué pour affronter tous les
chroniqueurs ce sont des questions
chiffres et si gilles est plus proche
que de la bonne réponse que les
chroniqueurs et gagner un cadeau si les
plus loin voilà il perd le canot il peut
conserver son cadeau ou décidé
d'affronter un autre chroniqueur pour
accueillir un cadeau encore plus ouf
d'accord vous ai compris ok ça on va
démarrer pour et on va jouer pour une
boîte de conserve au couscous garbit
d'accord c'est parti on va jouer contre
benjamin castaldi a à couscous garbit
pour benjamin castaldi
d'accord c'est parti voici la question
combien y at-il de divorce prononcé en
france chaque année
celui qui est le plus proche de la bonne
réponse gad alors castaldi tu démarres
yeux c'est 1500 combien 7500 7500 tu dis
combien gilles jemil 10 me et bien
sachez qu'il y ait en france chaque
année 90 milles divorce 90min bord alors
d'un 89 milles devant chamakh a failli
voit bien ce qu on est content ou pas
croyants et 90000 donc julien tu as
gagné ta boîte de conserve de couscous
garbit est-ce que tu gardes ta boîte de
conserve ou est-ce que gilles ou est ce
que tu veux
est ce que tu veux tenter le prochain
cadeau non le prochain cateau cyril
d'accord au risque de tout perdre du
jour la question
on joue pour 11 ou cours
je vous le dis un baba pérou le jeu le
ba-ba p o c'est un jeu de société de
moi-même d'accord tu joues tu joues
contre laurence ça y est quel est le
pourcentage de française qui possèdent
un ou des sextoys laurence ta réponse 30
% 30 % tu dis combien agile déjà j'en
suis sûr je le range là non je rigole
non mais on peut lui demander aux
français ce que vous en avez d'ailleurs
je rigole je rigole non mais juste tu
peux demander on se dit oui c'est mon
ami laurent ce temps là oui dans ce
cadre est à quoi tu as ta carte du parti
républicain déjà carrément des sextoys
lens n'est pas exceptionnel et pas
besoin
sophie sophie tonga mouais je recommande
absolument savez le magic wand en
anglais ça veut dire donc baguette maji
magique et ses annonceurs semblent
encore un micro comme l'aller les
anciens micro de michel drucker et ca
on appelle ça un vibromasseur en fait
ouais mais c'est top c'est exceptionnel
ça ressemble un peu à ça mais c'est trop
d'accord même genre et ça va oui donc
c'est ça s'appelle quoi c'est pas comme
ça mais le magic wand magic world ou
pleurer à end et vous pouvez commander
sur amazon
tu la commande et toi tu l'as à julie
bien son jeu laisse paraître que le
chercher tout à l'heure sur version
imagée et basso coup ça fait du bien à
retrouver lâche rien à la série et
j'adore donc que tu dis combien
pourcentage de personnes qui ont des
sexes correct
40 40 40 % pendant confinement tout
dépendra en période normale
on a essayé des 30% à les 22
22 sachez qu'il y à 14 % des françaises
qui possède un sextoy le record vient de
suède
les suédoises il y en a 43 % qu un
sextoy chez les suédoises et celles qui
en ont pas l on dit chris prolls le
shérif on joue pratiquement avec gilles
pour une enceinte bluetooth
est-ce que tu joues pour lancer un tout
tu me dis non je garde le barda perron
là je joue je continue tu joues pour
lens art
attention on va jouer avec gilles verdez
quel est le record actuel du plus grand
mené au monde
c'est 14 cm 14 cm tu dis combien gilles
l'autre gilles 14,5 14,5
je te le dis la bonne réponse c'est un
turc
il s'appelle mehmet oz urech je vais
failli l'invité sur une émission à jour
je vous dirais il fallait faire venir en
surprises de gilles voilà de turquie et
son nez mesure 8,8 cm et ouais et donc
c'est perdu ouais c'est perdu ouais
c'est perdu alors et tu sais quoi je
t'offre quand même un baba pérou
d'accord je tente quand même le ba-ba
perron et ouais mon chéri ouais ouais 8
cm et le plus grand n'est jamais mesuré
était de 10,9 cm
alors je me demande c'était vraiment en
est à mon avis ont foutu de la gueule
cette connerie c'est bon je suis écoeuré
là y'a bon moi tu sais quoi je vais
t'offrir quand même à un petit cadeau en
plus d'accords mongil merci merci merci
je t'offre enfin sur je t'offre en plus
à sur ces canaux magnifique je t'offre
en plus un robot cuiseur allergies ou le
bol à celui qui fait tout bas je
remercie s'irrite bas c'est normal vous
syrie mais quand il faut continuer comme
ça et on fait de natal et les peines un
thème bien cela je serai grand je
t'embrasse nrj 12 le cadeau moshiri je
t'embrasse très fort merci d'avant
et hélas